hey youtubers everybody had a bunch of
questions about the DC TV finale so I
decided to do a video ranking them all
against each other so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen them yet
there's this long history of the CW DC
shows teeing up what's going to be
happening next seasons they did a great
job of that this season so we have a
pretty good idea of what's going to be
happening and how each of the teams are
going to be changing but there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video and
because we're entering this summer make
sure you let me know in the comments
which of these shows you want me to do
bonus videos for because obviously the
flash is really popular but I don't
always get requests for other shows too
but it's always hard to tell if
everybody wants me to do a certain thing
so everybody be sure to follow me on
Twitter because I'll do a lot of
questions when I'm getting ready to do
videos at the beginning of the day like
so you want me to do XYZ this is where
that is just a variation on my channel
name I'll add a link for that in the
description but let's start with the
flash I've already done a couple videos
about the finale so to spend a little
bit of time on it but overall they're
just teasing Barry Allen being lost to
the Speed Force he's gone to heaven so
to speak so he's out of commission in
now Wally West is the main versions of
flash in Central City and Keith stone no
need to worry so even if Kid Flash
starts calling himself the flash I still
think that he's going to be in that
yellow costume because Kenyon Lyons Dale
the actor doesn't look super good in red
and Barry's going to be coming back at
the beginning of the season anyway so
he'll be back to being the main version
of the flash so it'd be really expensive
for them to make a red costume to only
use it once unless he was going to go on
to another TV show like Titans which is
a little soon to speculate about but
there's just so much stuff going on in
the Titans comic book now with the Wally
West flash there's two Wally West
flashes in the comics I don't think
they'll ever do ginger and
african-american wally west on the TV
shows but we'll find out more about that
this summer at Comic Con so Barry's gone
saboteur has been erased by a paradox
wave so all the things that he has done
have been wiped off the map with a few
exceptions Wally did not lose his speed
there are a couple lingering questions
so I'll do separate videos about that
there
a lot of people that were disappointed
by the way they wrapped up this Avatar
plotline letting iris West kill him with
a bullet I think the people were
expecting something a little more
spectacular so I still really like the
flash finale I'm much more connected to
those characters than I am the
characters from the comics on the other
TV shows so I just have a much deeper
connection with those characters even
though arrow had the stronger finale in
the stronger through line this season so
overall I give the flash of be for their
season they did some really cool stuff
but they meander through the first half
of the season they did their best to
juggle all the big characters they
introduced but I think that was part of
the problem as they had so many huge
characters from the comics so many
speedsters that it was just really hard
to give them all really meaningful
storylines so a couple of them like
Jesse quick Jay Garrick kind of got rid
off the back half of the show like
you're really important for a couple
episodes then we'll never see you again
so a bit of a disappointment I feel like
they'll fix that with season four
they've already teased who the villain
is it sounds like it's going to be de
vocht but there'll be a lot of other
villains that they'll bring on too so
get hype for all animals Suicide Squad
in a bunch of new robes but moving on to
the arrow finale probably my favorite
finale from all the DC TV shows because
it killed off a long-standing character
and it brought back some of my big
favorites in a really rewarding way and
just let them wreck all over the screen
it was so much fun
so when arrow comes to party they blow
it up big time literally in this case
arrow just tends to be more of a
hardcore show they didn't really have to
rely on huge twists like a phase
changing device to take back a big
character death they showed you that
someone was dead then the actor came on
John Barrowman is like I'm dead they did
it off screen but sorry it's been fun
it'll be interesting character
development for Thea's character next
season so it does seem like he's
actually dead now really can't say
enough about my new Ben at his death
stroke he posted this on Twitter a
little while ago just basically telling
the arrow writers to give him something
good and he would totally come back like
throwing the gauntlet down so that makes
me really excited for next season but
obviously because it's a huge
cliffhanger you don't know who lived who
died they have to pay that off in the
first episode so most of these
characters will come back in some way
and I do not believe for a second that
they would kill Deathstroke off screen
but a lot of people are sped
chelating now that the mother of
Oliver's child is dead and they say that
the theme of season six is going to be
family so William will be a much bigger
part of the story than he has been in
the past Prometheus was a much stronger
villain dance avatar in a much more
rewarding one given how long arrow has
been on the air there was so much more
backstory in context to what he was
doing and why he was pursuing Oliver
what his big bill and his plan was it
was kind of like the flash tried to do
something like that - only in half the
amount of time that arrow took to get
there so when Prometheus was showing
Oliver all of his past sins you just had
so many more seasons so many more dead
bodies so many more WTF moments to get
thrown back in his face and it meant so
much more for the character so the
culmination of that in the finale the
resolution was just a solid a and I
think everybody in general is just way
more hyped up for season six than they
were going into season 5 after season
four so there will be separate arrow
videos about what's going on next season
but moving on to legends of tomorrow so
I feel like that finale was probably a
solid b-plus it was a really fun show
they tried to have as much fun as
possible just jumping around space-time
reverse-flash the Legion of Doom were
amazing as villains I feel like they
made the season the writing for the
legends hero characters was way better
heat wave was much better this season
but I feel like the villains are always
a little bit more fun just because they
can do anything there's almost no rules
when you're a villain they went up
against the black flash so it was so
much fun to see one of my favorite
characters
eobard thawne be one of the focal points
for this season hopefully he'll come
back to the flash TV show very soon
because right now he is also in
speedforce heaven solid b-plus episode
just because at times it was all over
the place but finally Supergirl so this
is a show that is actually way bigger
than a lot of the other shows they do
galactic stuff they had this big alien
plotline they did a much bigger version
of the four-way crossover storyline
where Dax I'm invaded welcome to new dak
sim so if you've read the new Krypton
storyline they basically did a version
of that using the mod L character T's
all kinds of big things like war world
big concepts from the Superman comics so
it was very rewarding from a comic book
standpoint but the end of the season
they sent the Montell character off he
got sucked into a wormhole that looked
an awful lot like a time vortex my
takeaway from that is that the next time
we see him he'll be part of the Legion
of super-heroes whether or not they ever
actually get to that on the shows they
might just tease him in the costume look
I've been working with a team in the
future you'll never believe the places
I've been and then eventually they'll
work out to that but they did Legion on
Smallville so they can totally do it on
the DC TV shows right now they have done
way weirder stuff the other big villain
tees for next season is the rain
character so you flash back to Krypton
as it was blowing up in his car and
Superman are leaving the planet in their
ships there's also a separate ship by
this Kryptonian death cult where they
talk about this being who's going to
flourish and reign on earth but they
don't show you what the baby looks like
which i think is a twist because when
she comes out she's gonna look like this
so if you don't know who she is she's a
very doomsday like character she's
called rain the world killer but she was
a new 52 Supergirl character they never
really got around to fleshing out her
backstory too much so the TV show is
probably going to take a few liberties
but she's basically a doomsday level
challenge for Supergirl that's very
specific to her character so it's not
like they're borrowing a Superman
character this is straight out of the
Supergirl comics it was so much fun
seeing teri hatcher Kevin Sorbo came on
that was crazy and then they brought
Lynda Carter on so they bring it big
time but because I'm not super connected
to those characters not nearly as much
as I am to the characters on flash or
arrow I still gave the finale a solid a
- just because they did so many big
things but just ranking them all I still
feel like arrow probably had the best
finale the biggest payoff then you have
Supergirl with this huge worldwide
disaster the characters were great but
right after that about neck and neck or
flash and legends of tomorrow so I feel
like they all had good finales but some
of them were just a little bit stronger
than the others so let me know of all
the DC shows which finale was your
favorite and then which show is your
favorite because even though the flash
didn't have the strongest finale it's
still my favorite DC show just because
I'm so much more connected to those
characters so much more connected to
those comics like I just don't spend a
lot of time reading Supergirl comics I
don't read a lot of Green Arrow comics
all the time flash is one of the few TV
shows that I read regular
that will change when titans premieres
because i read a lot of teen titans i
read a lot of Nightwing a lot of Batman
everybody that reads comics reads a lot
of Batman but I'm really pumped about
the next season there was nothing that I
was really really upset with I feel like
they all met expectations the flash
could have been a little bit better
hopefully their storyline will be a
little bit stronger next season but
hopefully that explains a little bit
about what's going on with each of the
finales the big twist most of the shows
are coming to Netflix this week so if
you're not caught up now's the time to
do it but leave all your requests for DC
bonus videos in the comments below and
not that I've been neglecting it but
there will be some new Marvel coming
really soon - congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Carlos Moreno
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my non-spoilery Wonder Woman review and
you can click here for brand new flash
season 4 thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight